so candace owens is completely unafraid
of anyone so she's often accused of
things the new york times in its latest
salvo is accusing her of working for
vladimir putin
the reporter just wrote to kenneth owens
quote quote we note you have advanced
the idea that ukraine was you cropped
country which matched comments we've
seen from russian state media
calling ukraine corrupt is russian
propaganda so here's what candace owen
sort of responds i'm very confused by
this email i learned about ukraine's
corruption from the new york times
that's just one example here is a piece
of the new york times editorial board
entitled ukraine's unyielding corruption
greatest response ever
founder of the charity blexit candace
owens joins us now
that is just too great how did they
respond to you candace
i mean i also sent them even more links
i mean that was just one link that i
sent them but there's 10 20 links
between the washington post and new york
times of the last three or four years
telling us about how unyielding the
corruption is and really spelling out to
us how corrupt president zielenski is
but they've magically changed their mind
so i was confused maybe russian
disinformation means now for the new
york times truth given the hunter biden
laptop scenario which they called
russian disinformation and they now
acknowledge is fully true obviously he
responded and said thank you for sending
these links and then completely moved
the goal post and asked me whether or
not i accepted the official government
narrative regarding
bio labs and whether they were just
opened for research and i said this is
completely nonsensical what does this
have to do with your initial question
and then i sent another link and i said
is that the official govern government
narrative regarding bio labs is it for
research because you guys also told me
another article that they were funding
these labs to shut down previous soviet
labs um and then he just said thank you
for your time no more questions because
i don't think he's reading the new york
times and doesn't realize how many times
they pivot the narrative and here's the
thing we but nobody believes this
russian puppet stuff i mean it's just
ridiculous a black woman in the united
states have never even been to russia i
mean i i can't i can't think of a
russian food off the top of my head i
mean it's so ridiculous i refuse to give
it any error but they say these things
when you arrive at a truth that they
don't want them looking at that they
don't want the the public at large
looking at they say oh looky over here
never mind this person's a russian
puppet exactly like they did with the
hunter biden laptop until they were
ready to acknowledge the truth so i
really tried to reflect on what it was
that i was hitting at that was bothering
them and really it was me talking about
zielinski you know zelinski right now
according to the mainstream narrative
the new mainstream narrative i should
say is batman right we're all supposed
to just go he's an amazing hero and he's
not corrupt and i've been talking about
their previous covering of him in the
pandora papers talking about his ties to
you know ukrainian billionaires um that
are that are the whole have a
controlling interest in barisma that
might be a significant conversation for
the press to have in a moment when we
have biden's administration egging us on
trying to get us more involved in this
conflict in ukraine and they don't want
that conversation to be had so instead
they're going with a black female from
the united states is somehow on putin's
payroll which is just pointlessly
ridiculous
oh i know the feeling
[Laughter]
russian disinformation so the biden
family's patron's in trouble the us
military has to save him but mentioning
that
not allowed guinness owens fearless as
always i appreciate it thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else